[Music]
sometimes the greatest thrill is
discovering something that's been flying
under your radar
if you're chasing that feeling you've
come to the right place there's so much
to discover on netflix ranging from the
sublime to the ridiculous and back again
filmmakers josh and benny safdi
specialize in dizzyingly fast-paced and
complicated crime sagas
set on the fringes of new york starring
actors one wouldn't suspect
just before the duo made the acclaimed
uncut gems of adam sandler they
concocted good
time an innovative and twisty heist film
headlined by robert pattinson
the twilight star plays connie who
forcibly takes his developmentally
disabled brother nick
out of a therapy session because he
needs help robbing a bank
the getaway goes awry and police nab
nick connie forever protective of nick
then schemes to bust him out of police
custody in a hospital where he landed
after being attacked by another prisoner
the caper also involves at various turns
a valuable drug stash an aging long
island amusement park
the criminal underworld and mistaken
identity victor stiff of tilt magazine
calls good time a nerve-wracking crime
adventure
loaded with thrills sleazy characters
and a distinctly new york flavor
the setting of the frozen ground is
anchorage alaska in the mid-1980s
or at least a senior outskirts and
underbelly of the large city
rife with drugs and violent crime it's a
place where teenage runaways tend to
disappear forever
after one young woman escapes from the
clutches of a person of interest
job-weary law man jack halcomb connects
that case with those of other women
whose remains have been found in remote
wild areas and whose homicides have gone
unsolved for well over a decade
it's a chilling suspenseful and at times
deeply unsettling cat and mouse movie
based on the true story of alaskan
killer robert hansen made all the more
intriguing by john cusack
nicolas cage and vanessa hudgins all
playing against type
hollywood loves movies about
professional killers and with good
reason
being paid a lot of money to kill
another person is a strange
illegal reprehensible concept which
means there's no small amount of drama
involved
being a hitman is also absurd and that
makes for fertile ground for a hitman
comedy like killing gunther
you know it's nothing personal right
it's all business you want to be king
you have to kill the king and right now
gunther is king
a mysterious figure named gunther is
both the envy and bane of the tightly
near to worldwide community
of professional killers he always seems
to get the best gigs and makes everyone
else in the business look bad
prompting a ragtag group of hitmen to
join together and use their producer
skills as discreet assassins to finally
once and for all kill gunther however
gunther is the world's greatest hitman
so it's going to be a tough proposition
for the likes of skilled killers
like blake and sana revealing who
portrays gunther would spoil the fun
but suffice to say it's some perfect
casting in this enjoyable action comedy
eight-year-old alton meyer is the
adopted son of pastor calvin meyer
leader of a rural texas cult known only
as the ranch he's also got amazing
powers
like being able to shoot light beams out
of his eyes speak in tongues
and intercept satellite transmissions
the bad news for the special child
the fbi would love to capture him and
limit his unspeakably powerful gifts
alton goes on the lamb not only from the
government but also from the ranch
thanks to the help of his biological
father roy who kidnaps the boy away from
the religious group
that raced him and tried to harness his
abilities it turns out that those
abilities may be even more pronounced
than previously thought
and speak to earth-shattering hidden
truths midnight's special is a dazzling
film that takes this mystery
and runs with it in profound ways the
movie stardust is appropriately named
for a magical substance the stuff for
fairy tales because it feels like an
age-old bedtime story
it's actually based on a rollicking
adventure novel by neil gaiman that
dates back
only to the 1990s fully realized in
cinematic form by an all-star cast of
charming actors
tristan lives in a small old british
village of wall which juts up against
the magical kingdom of stormhold
one day he sees a star fall from the sky
and he aims to capture it and present it
as a gift to victoria
the woman he loves so as to secure her
hand in marriage
those plans change when he discovers
that the star is transformed into an
enchanting woman
named evan you're the star you're the
star
really tristan of course falls in love
with evan
and also has to help her escape the trio
of witches who wish to restore their
youth by eating a vein's heart
as if that wasn't enough for an
eye-popping imaginative story with
something for everyone
stardust also involves a flying pirate
ship helmed by the gregarious captain
shakespeare a battle between the years
of stormhold
and a secret magical heritage in short
there's something for everyone
some of the best horror movies generate
their scares by pulling from real life
possible terrors lurk everywhere in the
world john eric dowdell's 2014 effort as
above so below
places its characters one of the real
world's most chilling places
the catacombs beneath paris the final
resting place of countless centuries-old
human remains
the premise is also familiar inviting in
the possibility of even more effective
dread
archaeologist scarlett marlow thinks
that the legendary philosopher's stone
which can turn metal into gold
and grand eternal life is located
somewhere in the catacombs
she assembles a crew to venture deep
into the subterranean land of the dead
and not everyone from her team may make
it out in the years since its release
as above so below has kept growing its
audience among found footage horror fans
and with good reason he has a wildly
different and unpredictable movie that
merges together movie genres that often
rely so heavily on tropes that they're
overly familiar and predictable
in the shadow of the moon is part sci-fi
movie part mystery
and part serial killer story the film
begins in 1988
when philadelphia police officer thomas
lockhart his partner
and his detective brother-in-law
desperately tried to find and stop a
prolific killer
whose victims seem to lose all their
blood at once they find the suspect but
she evades capture by jumping to her
apparent death
flash forward nine years and the killer
is at work again
then another nine years and more
killings occur thomas becomes the
obsessed detective
researching the case for decades as his
quest leads him down the unexpected
crime-fighting path of time travel
in the shadow of the moon is never less
than engaging and it's just about always
clever
according to the new york times science
fiction movies don't have to rely on
state-of-the-art special effects or be
set on some distant planet in some
far-off year
dialogue driven sci-fi set in the
present day and produced on a moderate
budget
is possible and it can be spectacular
such as the case with jurassic world
director colin trevorrow's 2012 feature
debut
safety not guaranteed seattle magazine
writer jeff
pitches an investigative piece about a
weird classified ad
seeking a companion to travel through
time you'll get paid after we get back
must bring your own weapons i have only
done this once before the writer wants
enlisting interns darius and arnold jeff
tracks down the supposed time traveler
grocery store employee kenneth and
darius poses as an interested time
travel companion
hiding her journalistic connections as
it turns out kenneth is tragically
serious about going back in time
wanting to head to 2001 to stop the
vehicular death of his girlfriend
amazingly he may not actually be a
crackpot funny
strange and full of heart safety not
guaranteed is a masterclass in getting a
lot of sci-fi fern out of a tiny budget
according to the 2016 sci-fi horror
thriller the girl with all the gifts the
future looks bleak for humanity
while with an aggressive zombifying
fungus that turns the vast majority of
people into hungaries
quick and agile dead brained
flesh-eating monsters those that
resisted the fungus have figured out
that children are the future
specifically a small collective of
zombie human hybrids who still want to
eat people but are also capable of
rational thoughts and civilized behavior
among them is melanie apparently immune
to the fungus and set for scientific
dissection to help create a vaccine
but when the lab holding her is attacked
and destroyed by hungary's
melanie sets off on a journey of
identity exploration
against a backdrop of destruction and a
rapidly devolving civilization
the girl with all the gifts manages to
deliver on the horror goods while also
delivering a very human story
and offers something different for fans
who think they've seen it all from
zombie movies
the 2018 sci-fi thriller the endless
starts on a high note and somehow keeps
building
a decade before the events of the film
brothers justin and aaron escaped from
camp arcadia a ufo death cult as far as
justin was concerned but a silly far out
commune to aaron
one day the brothers receive a
mysterious cassette in the mail that
leads them to consider a return to camp
arcadia
apparently everyone is still alive
although justin is pretty sure they're
still planning a tragic mass death event
to ascend to an alien world
why do you want to go back
[Music]
you can say goodbye to some closure
welcome to back into the camp both
brothers realize that this particular
ufo death cult may have actually been
right about extraterrestrial life as
it's the only explanation for some
strange events and discoveries
such as a previously undiscovered color
and the existence of time loops
doom looms large as justin and aaron try
to figure out just what is going on
subtle inventive and deeply atmospheric
the endless is a masterclass in doing a
lot with a little
maniac is hard to categorize it's a
darkly comic often surreal and lightly
dystopian miniseries
set in a future world where gadgetry and
pharmaceuticals have rapidly progressed
but a 1980s consumer tech flavor
permeates the design of day-to-day life
desperate and guilt-ridden annie and
troubled rich family black sheep owen
locked down for a heavily controlled
psychological drug trial and a
mysterious drug company operated by the
eccentric dr james k
mantleray mantle ray is literally and
explicitly in love with machinery and
lives in the shadow of his mother dr
greta mantelray a popular pop
psychologist and best-selling author
that all fuses with journeys deep into
the minds of owen and annie and
sometimes both at once when their
subconscious realities intersect
who live out their deepest fears and
insecurities in desperate ways
such as an exotic animal heist and the
lord of the rings-esque fantasy
not only dazzling and challenging maniac
is visually stunning
psychologically dense and often
surprisingly emotional
all at once check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff to
watch are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one